-Welcome back. We're hanging out
with Miles Teller!
[ Cheers and applause ]
He is hosting "Saturday
Night Live" this weekend,
but first we're about to
face off in a game of Drinko.
Drinko, do you want to explain
how the game works?
-Yes. Welcome to Drinko.
In this game, the two of you
will take turns
climbing my stairs
and dropping two of your disks
down the Drinko board.
The disks will plink down
and land in these plastic cups
containing some of my favorite
beverages such as...
Girl Scout Thin Mints,
cream-cheese water,
and garlic shot.
Your opponent
must drink the cocktail
of the two chosen drinks.
-Alright. Thank you very much.
-Cheese water?
-Drinko, what did you say again?
Did you say --
-Cream-cheese water!
-Alright.
-♪ It's water
with cream cheese! ♪
-That's my favorite --
That's a great
Harry styles song.
♪ Cream-cheese water, ah,
cream-cheese water ♪
Alright, Miles,
why don't you go up there first
because you're our guest?
-Sure.
-Climb up the steps of Drinko
and enjoy yourself
a good beverage.
-Yes. Thank you.
-Yeah, no problem.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Drinko, you okay?
-Drop the disk whenever
you're ready, Miles.
-Alright.
-Here it comes.
Cream-cheese water!
-Alright. Your first cup
will be the garlic shot.
-Garlic shot!
-[ Sad tuba plays ]
-It's a garlic shot.
-That's healthy.
-That's healthy for you.
That's not that bad.
And then you're gonna mix that
with another beverage
once you drop the second chip.
-Drop your second disks.
Here it comes.
Coming down the stairway.
Ginger kombucha.
-Ooh. Not bad actually.
-Ginger kombucha.
-Oh, my -- I'm -- This is great.
-Miles, you have
ginger kombucha...
Thank you, Drinko.
-I think they sell these --
-You wanna take those?
-You can buy this shot in a
store right now for like $14.
-Yeah, that's actually not bad.
You've got ginger kombucha
and garlic shot.
Not bad.
-Ooh.
-Place it in this nice cup
right there and enjoy yourself.
A garlic shot.
[ Audience groans ]
-Mmm!
-Alright.
♪♪
Good luck. Good to see you.
-Oh!
-Oh, that'll help.
That'll help.
-God, it's --
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Ahh. I feel lighter.
I don't know. I feel --
I'm so much healthier
than you right now.
-Your Adam's apple was shaking
as you were drinking.
[ Gurgling ]
-Yeah.
-Now it is your turn, James.
-What do you want me to do,
Drinko?
-I want you
to ascend the staircase
and drop two disks in me.
-Okay.
-Drinko's getting
a little bossy.
-Drinko.
-I'm sorry. On me. All over me.
-Alright, all right.
-Climb the -- Unh! Eh! Ah!
Unh! Eee! Ooh! Ooh! Ohh...
Drop the disk, baby.
♪♪
-Alright. I want to stay away
from cream-cheese water.
-No.
-I'm going to throw up
if I do cream-cheese water.
Is that good right here?
-Here we go.
-No! Stay away from that side!
Yes! Good, good, good.
Oh, no, oh, no!
-No! Yoo-hoo!
-Yoo-hoo! Yes!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Drop the second disk.
-Ugh. Let's just do it.
Alright. Here we go.
-Come on, cream-cheese water!
[ Drinko grunting ]
-No, no, no. Please.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
-Hey!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Oh, James.
You must drink
my cream-cheese water.
-I hate this game. I --
I just -- It's not.
-That's the cream --
-It is not!
♪♪
Why in the world?!
-♪ Cream-cheese water ♪
Two drinks, one cup.
[ Audience groans ]
There you go.
♪♪
-Ugh!
-Cream-cheese water.
[ Laughter ]
-I mean, it might pair well
with Yoo-hoo.
-You can do it, James.
You can do it.
Oh, that's the Yoo-hoo.
♪♪
-[ Groans ] I really --
This type of stuff. I can't --
I can't do it. I can't.
Like --
-You can do it. You can do it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-[ Coughs ]
♪♪
[ Coughs ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Wow!
Ohh!
-How's that?
-Not so bad.
-It's so gross.
-Yeah.
-It's so --
What's the worst part is,
it's still in the beard.
[ Laughter ]
It is so gross.
Gosh, that is disgusting.
Okay.
-Cream-cheese water.
Are you ready
for the final round?
-Yeah. Okay.
This is gonna be a race.
We're both gonna climb up
there. It's not over now?
-No, one more round.
-What's the final round?
-Both of you climb up
and drop a disk.
Whosever first disk lands first
is the winner,
and the loser has to drink
the cocktail of both beverages.
♪ Let's go ♪
♪♪
-Oh. Wait. What is it?
-Both of you
climb up the stairs.
-Alright.
-Both of you drop a disk.
-We're dropping two disks?
-Yes, at the same time.
Whoever's disk gets there
first wins.
The other person has to drink
the drink, the loser's drink.
-I think the Drinko guy
is drunk. I don't think --
-Oh, yeah.
-That's why they call me Drinko.
[ Laughter ]
-Drinko, wait.
Where do we find you, Drinko?
-Ready?
I'm going to count to three.
-Drinko, where did we find you?
-You didn't find me.
I found you.
[ Laughter ]
-Alright.
So we're both dropping --
We're both dropping
at the same time.
-At the same time. I will
count down, "3, 2, 1, drop."
Are you ready?
-Yes.
Where are you putting yours?
On the line?
-Right here.
-Okay.
-3, 2, 1, drop.
♪♪
-Oh, I'm toast.
-Yo!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-What'd you get?
What did we get?
Is it more cream-cheese water!
This is the best game ever!
Drinko, Drinko, Drinko!
What did we get?
Yoo-hoo...
-Well, I think I've got the...
-And the garlic shot again?
Dude.
-Oh, garlic shot.
-What do you -- What do you --
I'll give you -- You can add
one more thing to mine.
-Okay.
-Bone broth.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Audience
shouting suggestions ]
-Mustard juice.
♪♪
Cream-cheese water.
-No.
[ Cheers and applause ]
They -- The audience
turned on me so fast.
It's like...
-They loved you
when you come out.
-I come out. They're like,
"Oh, 'Top Gun," this and that."
For this, they're like...
-"Cream-cheese water."
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-You guys are mean.
-Good luck. Are you -- Do you
have a good, strong stomach?
-No. I do have, like, a fairly
sensitive gag reflex.
-I can't think about what I did.
The Yoo-hoo helped me.
That's not Yoo-hoo.
That's garlic.
And that's the Yoo-hoo.
-Here comes the Yoo-hoo.
-I'm gonna add a little
cranberry into this one.
-Oh, my God.
-Take it to the "finish."
-That's a lot to chug.
-Turn and burn, baby.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh, my God! Legend!
♪♪
Legend right there!
Miles Teller!
How did you do that?